mélange de sang neuf et d'expérience le
québec obtient six ministres en excluant
justin trudeau
c'est plus de 20% des postes au cabinet
la plus grande représentation du québec
depuis plus d'une décennie
honnêtement ça fait une équipe qui va
certainement pouvoir bien saisir les
grands intérêts du québec le
gouvernement couillard se réjouit de
voir le premier ministre trudeau piloter
les affaires intergouvernementales et ça
va dans le sens de son désir qu'il avait
exprimée d'améliorer la collaboration la
coopération les discussions avec avec
les provinces mois stéphane dion
montréal à davantage de poids au cabinet
avec le nouveau chef de la diplomatie
ainsi qu'avec marc garneau aux
transports lui qui devra gérer le
délicat dossier du pont champlain
sans oublier mélanie joly au patrimoine
québec a aussi son représentant avec
jean yves duclos qui hérite du ministère
de la famille [ __ ] ministre autour de
la tam et c'est le seul ménisque ya
dedans c'est dans ses responsabilités
tout domaine social des bahamas alors on
est très heureux je pense un signe fort
du nouveau gouvernement de ministres
proviennent des régions au revenu dix
ans le bic civile de la gaspésie puis
marie-claude niveau de l'estrie au
développement international et à la
francophonie
six ministres pour le québec peut-être
mais aucun ministère à vocation
économique
ce que les nouveaux venus refuse de voir
comme un problème
québec est très très bien représenté
dans ce cabinet on est très très
contents
les francophones hors québec voit
l'arrivée des libéraux d'un bon oeil
notamment la nomination de dominique
leblanc comme leader parlementaire
et oui cette fois qu'on a vraiment
maintenant ottawa des gens avec qui on
peut travailler le maintien et la
croissance de ces communautés passe en
grande partie par l'immigration et la
nomination de john l'écart l'onu à ce
portefeuille rassure les leaders de se
mettre au travail en matière
d'immigration francophone
pour développer des nouvelles
possibilités qui vont nous permettre de
recruter davantage de francophones dans
nos communautés
justin trudeau veut rétablir des
relations plus harmonieuses que son
prédécesseur et pour les francophones
hors québec
l'arrivée des libéraux au pouvoir le
parti des langues officielles
ross les attentes ici marc godbout radio
canada à ottawa